foreign
[Music]
counting down the days to her Oscars
performance and her sons apparently
having major fomo about it it's amazing
he's a happy baby well baby boys
seemingly not so happy about missing his
mama's big Academy Awards debut a week
out the singer who's pregnant with her
and ASAP Rocky's second child shared
this pic of her little one crying the
caption a funny mom moment quote my son
when he found out his sibling is going
to the Oscars and not him so cute Riri
will perform her oscar-nominated song
Lift Me Up from Black Panther wakanda
forever
Mia
[Music]
and while her son won't be at the show
he's been by his mom's side in
preparation check out this sweet video
of the 10 month old sitting on her lap
while watching the music video for the
track
[Music]
it really feels Like A lot's happening
all at once it feels like motherhood
Oscars Super Bowl baby number twos
definitely getting in on all the action
though the Oscars will be their second
life performance with Mama the first
came during her Super Bowl halftime show
where she dropped her pregnancy news
[Applause]
it's an Entertainer's dream to be on a
stage like that but don't worry her
firstborn also had a big first making
his magazine debut on the cover of
British Vogue alongside his parents
[Music]
let me awake
oh my God what are you enjoying about
this journey with three right now
everything about it I'm loving it
Rihanna and Rocky are excited about
their growing fam A source told E.T last
month the singer adores being a mom and
it's her biggest accomplishment in her
life quote they've been talking about
expanding their family for quite some
time being a mom is a dream come true
for Rihanna and she takes so much pride
in it I'm still pinching myself really
I'm grateful I'm grateful
foreign